while someone promised quite a lot there
thank you all for coming I know you have
a choice of talks to go to so thank you
very much and also thanks for sticking I
know you're sticking with my data for
two full days of talks it will not be
too mathematical hopefully for Sunday
afternoon so I went on the internet this
week and I found this now I'm not going
to be talking about this type AI for
energy I'm going to actually be talking
about fairly implementation and we're
going to talk about implementation I'm
going to be talking about as a specific
tools that we use so this is not going
to be a marketing slide about always
marketing debt about how we are going to
revolutionize everything with AI now why
is machine learning important in
particular in this energy industry well
this is one of the reasons so this plot
shows every day since 2012 and it shows
a percentage of the UK energy as it was
generated from burning coal so we can
see some very positive developments in
fact and in I don't know if you have
been following the news more recently
we've had some prolonged stretches of
extremely low fraction of coal on the UK
grid in part due to good weather in part
due to sort of policies and politics and
various shifts in the landscape but that
comes with its challenges and I'll try
to outline some of them very quickly so
the traditional energy grid it basically
has the supply was a generation side we
have some big power plants you turn them
on their run for months they've done a
lot of whatever it is then there are
some intermediaries there are some
markets and if you're a domestic
customer if your household you probably
have heard of the big six you may have
had your energy delivered by iana
British Gas for decades and the
household is sort of it just sits there
for 20 years and consume some energy now
things are changing things are changing
across the spectrum things are changing
as a generation side we now have far
less predictable generation from
renewables there weather-dependent
we
much less centralized and more
distributed generations a solar plants
tend to just be spread out in lots of
little patches we have changes from the
domestic side customers are getting
smarter homes they're getting a
battery-powered vehicles that place new
demands on the grid but they also
installing their own generation right so
octopus energy as a consumer facing
retailer we said somewhere in the middle
now of course we love doing things
better than the big six and we love
doing it with data and technology and we
have a lot of projects across the
spectrum but one of the key reasons why
we're in a position to do what I'll be
talking about is quite simple we know
where our data is and actually it's
surprising how many companies don't so
given that we know where our data is we
can make graphs like this right we can
make graphs like this so here is a
particular week from some months ago
where there was there were several dates
in green you can see the green energy
generation this is what 10 gigawatts of
wind on the grid and overlaid on top of
the Green Line which shows the wind
generation is the price signal so this
is where the only retailers that offer a
fully dynamic price signal to our
customers if they choose to as there are
people who are mining Bitcoin when the
price dips
it's an early adopter thing at the
moment but we can we can do this right
so we can pass this pricing on to the
customer and the price signal can go
negative now the price signals a
reflection of the imbalance between
supply and demand and the markets and
the grids efforts to balance it out
because electricity has to keep flowing
you can't just store it very easily
right which is one of the challenges and
then we can look at our customers and we
can look at the smart meter data that we
have been gathering over the last year
and a half maybe and we can do various
things we can see we can plot all the
customers who are on a fixed tariffs
versus all the customers who are exposed
to this dynamic pricing and we can see a
completely different consumption
behavior now this is something the
National
or many other companies do not see
because they don't have this data right
we can look at it bottom up so we can
see this massive change the blue is more
representative of what the industry
thinks everyone looks like but we know
that each customer has a different
consumption profile and in fact many of
these people have a massive spike at
night because I know the price is
cheaper we can see when they're charging
electric vehicles and we can see that
now of course we have helped this a
little bit by sending a few
notifications and press releases because
negative pricing while it's just another
number right it does generate some
headlines
so people suddenly charge about twice as
many EVs and you know they save a few
pennies and we do genuinely pay them I
mean so you have a unit rate usually you
pay I don't know 10 people kilowatt hour
right now the price owns and grid it
fluctuates all the time depending on
supply and demand if there is a huge
oversupply it's really windy the market
can starts pushing the price down there
is an auction happening and basically
that price can be pushed negative when
you get paid to take off the energy
because it's too expensive to dump
energy it's very difficult you can't you
know you can pump water uphill you can
do various things but yeah so and we
pass it on to consumer to consumers on
this particular tariff okay so this is
the sort of data that we're dealing with
and we can disaggregate it further we
can look at customer level and then we
start seeing this now we have tens and
tens of thousands of these time series
and one of the key challenges that will
enable us or already enables us to do
better to make better trading decisions
to make better hedging decisions but
also feeding into work like optimizing
batteries for the day ahead to better
make use of these imbalances is being
able to forecast this now as you can
imagine it's quite noisy and you know
this is the sort of challenge that we
are facing by the way in case anyone was
looking at this IDs and singing of the
German tank problem and how many
customers we actually have it's actually
quite public we are very open about how
customers we have so we have about
77,000 smart meters and this about 10%
of our total customer base so and that
red line at some point that the red line
was going up at such a slope that I was
worried if we can scale quickly enough
but you know luckily it flattened off a
little bit so the rest of the talk is
less about energy and more about sort of
how we approach timeseriesforecasting
and I think timeseriesforecasting has a
bit of a reputation within the data
science community and it's it's often
considered difficult it's often
considered a separate field and I think
some of the main reasons is that there
are so many approaches and this is
compounded by the fact that there are so
many approach is emerging from different
communities different topical
communities different fields of machine
learning and mathematics and this makes
it certainly for me when I started it
made it very difficult to know where to
start you're kind of torn between so
many different approaches so try to
demystify this a little bit and of
course bias it towards how we do it but
without pretending this is the only way
right so fundamentally what we are
dealing with like was any machine
learning problem we have some features
and we have some targets we are
predicting a value we want to know how
much energy is this household going to
need you know on this date at this time
and then we can sit down and think about
what our features are but the first
thing we need to decide is at the
regression problem yes basically
timeseriesforecasting is a regression
problem and that kind of points you to
the right half of scikit-learn so and
then you can ask yourself what are the
features obviously time itself is a
feature now pandas has date/time as a
type and lots of other libraries do
scikit-learn does not like date/time as
an input type so this is something we
need to think about but other than that
it's just a regression problem now the
final point that I would get to in this
talk is as you saw the behavior is quite
unpredictable in
our case we expect to be inaccurate and
I'll talk about what this means so we
should start worrying about predicting
some probability distributions which we
do routinely in classification we say
this is a 70% likely to be a cat
but with regression we often predict a
single number so I'll talk about that
right so I said we have the features and
we have the target and then people come
and say ok but I read about all these AR
models and ARIMA models and a gazillion
other models I mean yes and the reality
is you can always draw the sort of
diagram where YT is the point you're
trying to predict and so this is in the
sort of loosely applied plate notation
so for each time step you you just draw
the arrows what does it depend on well
in the simplest case it just depends on
some features that themselves depend on
time in some more complicated totally
aggressive case the previous value is
included with the features right so it
may not be computationally efficient to
treat it in the same way as there's a
features but ultimately that's what it
is why depends on these all of those
features including previous values
sometimes we want to use latent variable
models which is something the sort of
PGM the probabilistic graphical model
community is a Stan community is very
familiar with so there we want to have
some variables per consumer so think of
these squares as four loops right to the
inner for loop is over time and the
outer for loop is over customers or
households so we could have a latent
variable per customer that somehow
effects the outcome or even external
features per customer rather than per
time step and we can draw these diagrams
in any shape now another popular
approach to Auto regressive models is to
first aggregate the previous data right
using some form of encoder and then we
use that encoding as an input feature to
the next step by mixing it with the
other features so it's a bit simplistic
but it really captures every possible
time series forecasting model so
by going to general sort of maybe it
doesn't really tell you how to implement
it right so people look at these arrows
and these models and some people will
say you know we can use stand we can use
base in modeling other people will use
their favorite technique right now we
went down the deep learning route and
one of the key reasons and I think this
is one of the main sort of success
stories of deep learning I mean it's
very powerful in tasks that were
impossible before but it scales
extremely well all the sort of Markov
chain Monte Carlo methods they don't
scale nearly well enough and remember we
have where we have sort of approaching a
billion data points which I know sort of
people from bigger companies probably to
laugh at but we also have hundreds of
thousands of time serious as we forecast
simultaneously and we only expect this
to grow so we went down the deep
learning route and in fact what has been
done recently with language modeling
with all the other approaches it gives
us a sort of dictionary how do we
translate terms from other fields into
deep learning so basically if you're
familiar with sort of a are models and
you have excellent and the features you
see translated into sort of features as
the eggs of features the features
obviously anything a are becomes an
encoding of your time series latent
variables become embeddings and I'll
talk a lot about embeddings and then
anything that has to do with sort of
signal processing filtering smoothing it
can all be done with convolutional and
recurrent networks right so you know you
pitch that to your colleagues and if you
work with guys like Jamie says sure
let's do it
so okay so this is the sort of thing
that we are looking to implement right
and we have the choice we have a lot of
choices we have some data and features
we have some household features which we
can feed to an embed uh and I know there
are several talks mentioning embeddings
sort of this weekend and we can also
look at the most recent raw data itself
and we can pass it through an encoder
and now this is where it gets tricky
those of you who tried forecasting stock
prices with the less DM so that like no
it's actually very easy to get the next
step ahead seemingly very accurate and
very hard to do to go beyond that as I
will not talk much about the encoders
I'll just say sort of when we do use it
it's mostly not worth the computation
time in terms of improvements we get and
also we need to sort of pre-trained it
was an encoder decoder architecture cell
not go into that in this talk okay so
let's start with the input features now
here I debated a little bit whether I
should show codes it uses a library that
no one else has so we just open sourced
it and maybe some people will find it
useful
it's basically allows us to feed data
from pandas dataframe through
scikit-learn pipelines and into chaos
models with multiple-input
multiple-output so I'll just leave it at
that but other than that the code should
be easily recognizable we take the
date/time we experimented with different
ways of encoding date/time we generate
some extra features like you know day of
week they're a fractional hour this is a
bit simplified and then we encode those
features in different ways so and we end
up with something like this so maybe for
the time of day we we like using
periodic features so we use the sort of
sine and cosine feature which is a very
useful trick by the way for day of the
week we use sort of one hot feature so
you can see is that Monday is a Tuesday
is it Wednesday or whatever right and
then we have some seasonal features
across the duration of the year and then
we would add any external features from
the weather and such like ok so then we
need to build a neural network that at
the moment exists in Karis world but we
would like to plummet to those features
now this is where it gets a bit
interesting so I showed you this diagram
with multiple parts of the model and we
would like to be able to access the
encoder we would like to be accessing
better we would like to be able to
access a combined model in various
scenarios so the way we handle it we
define several sort of karats models
that share the computation graphs as I
share the layers potentially the inputs
and then we just you know all we need is
a dictionary of the shared model so we
can address one or the other and call
predicts on each one of them so as you
can see embedding there is an embedding
layer in chaos who here
you scare us actually most people yes
this should be very familiar right this
is a very simple model so we take the
embedding we take the external features
concatenate feed it to some dense layers
actually I don't know how many I left
one dense layer here yeah ok so a few
more layers but that sort of thing yeah
it looks like this right now because we
defined it as a dictionary here with
some convenience methods we can feed in
just a household ID and get out the
embedding by just calling this model dot
predict on this model all we can feed it
both inputs and get a sort of overall
prediction we can compile each sub model
and so on right then we do the plumbing
as we take those feature pre-processing
pipelines
it could be daytime pipelines encoders
it could be anything and we just say
which inputs of which models are are in
better model has one input and it has an
output but we don't really care and then
for the forecaster model it has two
inputs in this case and one output and I
feel like most of the scientists have
written some kind of pandas column
select a pandas value select a
transformer this sort of thing and
scikit-learn is actually getting better
but I feel it's not quite there yet in
terms of feeding pandas directly into
models right and then we end up with
this object so this object that we use
it allows us to fit the original model
so it provides a familiar API and it has
the extra keyword argument which is just
a model name right but the details are
not important basically we can train the
full model including the embedder on the
whole data set we can batch it the way
we want we can use batch generators
which is particularly important when we
do actual sequence encoding because we
can't preach ener 8 all the patches in
memory because one time series can yield
any number of overlapping windows as we
do it sort of online during the training
we can then do things like we can freeze
everything except the embedder which is
particularly useful if we train a big
model but then you add an extra customer
right and this is where embeddings have
a huge advantage of let's say one hot
encoding right we don't really want to
encourage one
hundred thousand customers one hot butt
represented assigning a fixed-length
embedding gives us the representations
the customers it's easy to Train easy to
update and actually gives us some neat
features further down the line that we
can use in other models now by having
this encapsulated models it's a bit on
the production side we one of the
reasons to encapsulate all this in a
single model object that includes the
feature pre-processing that includes a
sort of simple dot fit that predict API
is to make it easier to run in
production and the main reason for that
is because we have a very small team and
we have no one to hand it off to so we
can't just say okay here's a notebook so
having this model that has a dot fit
that project and we put it you know we
put our framework and all the
dependencies in a docker container and
we can run it we can schedule it we can
run it all through this we can run it
monthly we can run it weekly and we can
do different updating so here I'm
showing how new data is coming in new
customers are getting edit right and
every time we do updating we only update
the final layers in this case this is a
representative of just the embedding
part so we update the model this
embedding themselves will evolve over
time and maybe someone comes up with a
new model we deploy a new model and it
starts running every months it does a
big training run every day we use it to
generate some forecasts for traders okay
so we do all that so what does it look
like well it doesn't look too great you
can hopefully see that those customers
are randomly selected except this one
this is our CTO those models are kind of
capturing the behavior but it's actually
very difficult to see how well they're
doing now of course we're doing
cross-validation and we're looking at
error metrics which gives us sort of a
good indication of how the models
compared to each other
but you can probably anticipate that if
one of these spikes is someone putting
on a cattle it's very difficult to
predict and we are not claiming to be
able to do that it looks a lot better if
we aggregate it if we aggregate the
large set of customers as you would
expect and a lot of the time for
trading decisions is what we care about
and if we look at the individual
customers and we do some aggregation
what the model clearly does learn if we
are great enough it learns that this
customer mostly has a higher consumption
in the evening hours this customer has a
higher consumption in the morning hours
and this customer has a higher
consumption at night time compared to
the other customers so the model and
then you can start tuning your hyper
parameters and comparing different
models and all that so we can look at
the embedding space I mean I don't know
if it creates the illusion of being
three-dimensional but it is sort of
three dimensional different people see
different things in this space long
enough now I you can color it by
different things you can color it by the
sort of total consumption yeah you can
color it by various ratios you can color
it but the important thing is it groups
similar customers in the similar area of
the latent space which is something that
has been demonstrated was wet of his
word vectors time and time again we
obviously didn't invent this approach
but it's very useful in work so well in
so many areas right and we can we can
then do nearest neighbor in this space
if we want some clustering in categories
of customers right now how do we deal
with the errors and you may notice I'm
noticing that I'm running out of time
very soon so we look at the errors and
we find that our errors themselves are
actually quite badly behaved as they are
not Gaussian they sometimes have sort of
double peaks they have fat tails
horrible so how do we deal with that
well the first thing we can ask
ourselves can we actually improve the
model is it the model that is to blame
there is no definitive answer we can try
we can add more features we can do
cross-validation and hyper parameter
optimization but in practice there is no
way of knowing if you have exhausted
your feature space and if what is
remaining is the real underlying
stochasticity right we're not talking
about sort of hidden variables in
quantum mechanics here there is no way
of knowing now however we would like to
have a view of this errors not least
because this feeds into trading
decisions our trading decisions mean
money and you know someone will come and
complain about poor forecasts eventually
so what do we do about it well first we
need to recall why we used what we
optimized in the first place we optimize
the mean squared error because it's what
you do for regression because that's
what every single regressor does why do
we optimize mean squared error
well we optimize mean squared error
because we are assuming something about
the underlying distribution we are
assuming that our underlying
distribution is Gaussian we are assuming
even more we're assuming that this Sigma
is constant so we are assuming
homoscedasticity of a data and we only
fitting this mean we are fitting an
estimator to the mean of this
distribution and then we can do the
likelihood calculation that I'm not
going to go through this but if you do
the maths you're trying to maximize the
likelihood of the parameters that you're
estimating given the data we can
implement so Kerris when you do chaos
loss equals MSE it really construct some
computation graphs it looks like this it
takes the features and feeds through the
prediction model it takes a target it
computes the loss and then sort of back
propagates through here right except we
never feed the target in explicitly but
we can we can define our own loss
function what I've done here I've abused
caressed by passing it an identity loss
function and then calculating the loss
in an actual separate lambda layer right
as there are actually examples as if you
if you're not following all those are
examples online I'll share some links to
we can take it further
we don't need to say that Sigma is
constant we can make Sigma itself a
parameter of the model and this will
allow us to capture the behavior where
the errors are bigger at certain times
of day or for certain input features but
this still leaves us with a Gaussian
right keep that now there is a useful
trick that was introduced sort of by
Bishop of the book of the textbook Fame
a while back and I it doesn't seem to be
used very much but you can approximate
any arbitrary distribution
right as a sum of several gaussians as
if we output instead of outputting a
single mean in the same single Sigma
Sigma we output several of those and
adds them up we can approximate any
distribution so you can approximate sort
of distributions like this you can
approximate multi value distributions
where you see have sort of three
components three mixture components and
the color indicates the strengths the
weight and the sort of switches between
the components you have some switching
behavior you can basically do Markov
chains in continuous space okay so we
can do this in chaos right so again as
long as your Sigma as long as your
Sigma's are non-negative your means are
real valued and your weights add up to
one via softmax you're good to go so we
can optimize that right now in practice
training these models can be a bit
tricky as I do tend to get stuck a
little bit you have to be careful with
your learning rate annealing and the
gain sort of we don't want to go into
too much detail but at the end of the
day so here we fitted to that previous
data that I showed before and this is
not a single customer this is a
portfolio level right where we actually
usually care about the risk at portfolio
level so I've fitted a three-component
I think it was three component it could
be five it's just some components tend
to converge to zero so you end up you
have automatic selection in some sense
of the number of components so here as a
sort of individual Sigma's of the
different components and actually you
can see this is Saturday Sunday where we
have much higher variability you have
sort of individual means and you can
compute the aggregated mean and standard
deviation but your distribution is no
longer constrained to being Gaussian
which is very useful and it allows you
to model distributions with sort of a
narrow central peak and wide tails at
the same time or a distribution that's
not symmetric right so we can use these
models for sampling and in fact tens of
flow it's amazing what you find in terms
of flows these days you can do sampling
directly in terms of flow where I
initially I sort of exported everything
to numpy yeah
need to as you can extract random
samples as part of your model you can
then compare the distributions of the
real data with the sample data and most
importantly you can do that all of this
is has some seasonality to it so you are
inevitably forced to aggregate over
either certain hour a certain season but
for each of those your model gives you
assuming you trust your model right no
one said that is a model that it removes
all the if sort of cross validation
requirements but you get a pretty good
approximation you get this multi
modality of price and this is where
we're looking at this prices when you're
positive and negative on the sort of
last minute imbalance market and then
you can sample from that now this is
simply one step ahead sorry this is a
sampling right from this distribution
and it looks wrong because a real
portfolio doesn't behave like this
jittery mess now the reason it doesn't
behave like this jittery mess is because
it has some autocorrelation which we
haven't included right so let's include
that we include it was a previous time
step as an extra feature if we sample
one step ahead you can't quite see it on
the screen but see the variance goes
down a lot once we condition it on the
previous point as one of the input
features but then we can sample
iteratively just like we do when we
generate text so we can generate one
step at a time and we get these smooth
curves that again you can't see very
well because of the resolution but maybe
I can make it bigger no that doesn't
help at all yeah okay I'm glad I see SS
is not my strong point so yeah so you
can sample realistic portfolio scenarios
that are distributed in this high
dimensional time city of space it has as
many dimensions as there are time steps
right and you can sample from that space
using this one step ahead sampling and
you can try to perturb it you can say oh
what if my portfolio suddenly consumes
five times as much as it usually does
and it does tend to revert it does is
the model does tell you yeah no that's
not
and the model just reverts back to the
more expected behavior
oops sorry okay so we can do this with
price and volume separately and we can
plot one against the other and the all
looks fairly well now something that is
anyone here in finance yeah so I don't
know probably people in finance are very
concerned about long tails and
correlations and in particular sort of
tail correlation saves there is a point
up here where our customers suddenly
consume way more than we sought and at
the same time the price spikes you know
this is a huge exposure to us and we
haven't talked about correlations at all
and I'm not going to talk much about
correlation I'm just going to say that
with within the same framework within
tens of flobiz in Cara's we can compute
things like quantiles which means we can
project we can take out the seasonality
we can take out the daily behavior and
we can plot each point in terms of the
quantile within the volume space and the
quantile within the price space if we
map we once we have removed the
seasonality we can basically see if
there is an accumulation of points in
the top right corner and this is
specific months some months clearly are
more exposed to these tails than others
so we can suddenly see those tails and
these plots and shows that we need to do
something we need to do some modeling to
account for the higher likelihood zedzee
events at the far end of the price
spectrum and at the far end of the
volume or consumption spectrum will
correlate and of course we don't want to
leave tensorflow so we just implement
another model which has its own
likelihood and this class of models is
this is called a copula model right and
then we end up with something like this
and it gets increasingly complicated but
actually it's not as because tenza flow
allows you to construct an arbitrary
graph and not just a stack of dense
layers it's perfectly suited for doing
stuff like this so you can so here's
some volume sampling volume mixture
density Network so there will be an
output somewhere that has
the loss for fittings that part of the
network there will be an output for the
likelihood loss for fitting the price
part of the network there is some other
network doing the copula which is taking
outputs from these samples right and
there will be another model so just say
this is not to tell you how to do copula
modeling as more about practical
considerations when implementing these
types of models right and the practical
consideration is make use of sort of
predefined layer stacks as many people
have done service ResNet and the like
and make use of this model sharing and
sharing the computational graph between
multiple models and so if you define
several interconnected models you can
then call each one of them and if you
train one the weights become immediately
available to the other and this is
something that gives you a lot of power
and a lot of control so what are the key
takeaways from this talk and of course I
wanted to interest some people in this
energy space it's a very exciting space
lots of things are happening with new
data becoming available the markets
changing in the way they operate
obviously challenge your brands like
octopus energy eating into British Gas
and it's a big success customer base but
more importantly the first point is that
time series unscary
forecasting time series is to logic
sense a simple regression problem if you
engineer your features right you usually
do not need to worry about lsdm sons
alike and in fact I would argue that it
should always be the first step
engineering date time features is
something that is sort of discussed that
maybe there is no standard approach you
don't have a date time feature in coder
in scikit-learn but you do in that
github repos that are linked to deep
learning deep learning frameworks yes we
have several layers which makes it a
deep learning model but the main power
of the tensor flow and caris framework
for us is that flexibility it gives us
an constructing computational graphs and
yes we can do CNN sometime serious but
this is not the main takeaway the main
takeaway is you can do layer sharing you
can train different parts of the model
and you've
very flexible the third point is really
you can embed anything so we've heard
about embedding products embedding users
in this case we're embedding households
and their energy consumption patterns
and the final point is and this is again
something that I find is neglected a lot
when discussing regression is the
probabilistic aspect of it when you do
classification you always have a soft
max output with probabilities before you
reduce it to a single label with
regression it's more difficult to do
potentially or it's done less often but
in many cases like ours the prediction
itself is probabilistic so when we are
looking at the errors when we're looking
at the mean squared error what we
capture is not the fact that we haven't
built a good enough model but the fact
that we are trying to predict something
that is inherently stochastic and making
this distinction for your specific
problem you may be more towards one end
or towards the other end and this will
sort of inform with whether this is
useful to your problem but for us and
especially in terms of quantifying risk
it is very useful so there are some
links and the slides will be online in
fact actually here's a link to the
slides but I'll post it on slack as
there is so you can you can have a poke
around this framework that allows us to
build this interconnected models and
connect them to scikit-learn pipelines
there are some related projects that I
haven't worked with personally but they
seem to be thinking in similar
directions to what we do of maybe okay I
shouldn't take too much great we are
thinking in similar directions to how
tens of flow core devs think and there
are some open datasets as well so you
can't have our smart meter data yet but
there are smart meter data sets from
research projects as there are datasets
for wind and solar generation by site
and I think this is a great space there
is not a standard time series data set
like M Nestorian at right but there are
many data sets out there that allow you
to experiment allow you to try different
things so yeah that's that with me was a
constant in the friendly octopus hiding
up there
well and if you use this email here you
can reach me and if you use this link
here shameless plug
I get 50 pounds and you get 50 pounds
and you get hundred percent green energy
and the 50 pounds that you don't get we
spend it on GPUs thank you very much
any questions hey you go great talk I
just want to ask do you and do you how
do you think about the amount of data
before you kind of start thinking about
regression or deep learning is that
something that you take into account or
is that you just have a threshold and
after that point you just you can do
whatever you like it's it's difficult
there were several factors here why we
think deep learning is a way forward so
there was a great talk about profit
earlier yesterday maybe profit is great
if you have a single time serious profit
is great it does if basically does a
hierarchical basin model it works well
see you don't have a scalability issue
and also if you don't have this linked
behavior between multiple customers
right you don't benefit much from the
embedding from the transfer learnings
that it allows you to do whereas in our
case we want to be able to have
differentiable latent variables which
allow us to do effectively transfer
learning between customers and apply one
customer seasonality implicitly to a
customer who's only been with us for a
month right and project ahead but also
in terms of scalability deep learning
predictions scale linearly in the amount
of data or you scale horizontally but
training itself scales sub linearly
because you just you know you would
think you need to go through more and
more data and you do but you tend to
converge a bit faster so it's actually
sublinear which makes it super super
attractive to us
because we expect this amount of data to
grow tenfold hundredfold fimo this is
really great thank you and on the note
of the embeddings do you retrain them
periodically or you do you update them
and then also have you looked at the
temporal evolution and of the embedding
space things yes on both accounts we
have so this is what I tried to indicate
here whereas the individual embed
schematically admittedly way an
individual embedding starts somewhere
then as we retrain it moves a little bit
over time
yes we haven't done enough in that space
because you know we have some
constraints is they definitely evolved
at the moment when we do reduce the full
model run including all the dense layers
on top we lose the original embeddings
there is a very interesting paper from
what was called face net where as they
construct facial embeddings and they
talk actually in the appendix they talk
about how to update a model or implement
the new model that is compatible with
old embeddings is something we haven't
done but it's definitely possible one
final question please somebody from the
back maybe I might have missed this but
how do you do cross-validation in this
setting okay so we do temporal cross
validation we you know we train up to a
certain date and then we use sort of the
window months or a certain fixed size
window ahead of that for cross
validation during development we were
working with a much smaller data set and
we could do three four five fold in
practice I'm not going to pretend that
we do five fold cross validation
everything because it does take a long
time to train but on the plus side what
we do we run multiple models side by
side which includes trainings and
monthly with cross validation on a
single split and then a month later we
get another split and a month later we
get another split and we can effectively
look back over the past six months and
see which of the models has been
performing better
and we can on the fly simply tell the
traders which model to create cool
one final sorry we're out of time for
questions one final round of applause
for eco please
[Applause]